ws contra klima während auf der iaa
besucherströme den neuen autos bestaunen
erobern radler die autobahn und fordern
eine verkehrswende großputz am rheinufer
europaweit sammeln tausende freiwillige
tonnen von müll pionier des
umweltschutzes vor 250 jahren ist
alexander von humboldt geboren
deutschlands größter universalgelehrter
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg und ich freue mich dass
sie dabei sind wie auch norbert könig
für den spann absolut schön genannt es
galt als des deutschen liebstes kind das
auto doch dieser status bröckelt längst
das zeigte sich heute bei der iaa in
frankfurt laut und deutlich
noch nie hat die branche auf ihrer
leistungsschau so massiv gegenwind
bekommen
am ersten publikumstag der messe
drängten sich zwar wie gewohnt massen
von autobegeisterten durch die hallen
doch draußen protestierten tausende für
eine verkehrswende ihr vorwurf die
branche seien nicht entschlossen genug
beim wandel zu alternativen antrieben
susanna santana berichtet für diesen
moment haben sie die autobahn richtung
frankfurt übernommen
tausende fahrradfahrer die aus wiesbaden
gießen oder aschaffenburg haben
sie protestieren für einen
klimaneutralen verkehr der so schnell
wie möglich kommen soll
auch von der frankfurter innenstadt
zogen demonstranten zu bis zu 15.000
fordern die verkehrswende wir brauchen
den stadtumbau ganz klar und wir
brauchen auch mehr angebote im
öffentlichen verkehr in der fläche
es geht einfach darum zu denken und
nicht an alten techniken immer
festzuhalten nur weil es am meisten geld
für den moment bringt das umdenken ist
bei der diesjährigen iaa allgegenwärtig
die branche steht unter druck und setzt
auch elektro autos wie vw mit seinem id3
der knapp 30.000 euro kosten soll
am ersten besuchertag kamen mehr als
60.000 und man spürt das thema klima ist
auch bei den auto liebhabern angekommen
natürlich interessiert insbesondere der
stand der elektrofahrzeuge also wie viel
können die fahrzeuge tatsächlich auch
kilometer mäßig leisten
ich denke das ist eine ganz gute
alternative jetzt zu den benzinern und
dieseln dadurch dass sie immer mehr
städten verboten
doch auch für die ps starken modelle
gibt es nach wie vor eine kundschaft und
die automobilhersteller bedienen sie wie
mit dem fast 650 ps starken lamborghini
urus oder dem suv von audi mit fast 290
ps
wir haben auf jeden fall an den großen
suvs dass man auch auf fortfahren kann
ich bin auch einen sehr vifen also das
einfach auch als statussymbol vor allem
dass man ein schönes auto
doch es wird schwerer für solche wagen
das haben heute auch die massiven
demonstrationen gezeigt
wir lassen niemanden ertrinken sagt
innenminister seehofer und kündigt an
dass deutschland einen fixen anteil der
bootsflüchtlinge aufnehmen wird die in
italien eintreffen
mehrere eu staaten darunter deutschland
arbeiten an einem vorteil abkommen
ganz aktuell führte ihre
aufnahmebereitschaft zu einem ende der
irrfahrt der ocean walk in christiane
hübscher der moment als die 82 migranten
auf dem rettungsschiff erfahren dass sie
an land gelassen werden
[Musik]
der italienische außenminister erklärt
warum man den hafen heute öffnet es
haben sich neue mechanismen entwickelt
automatismen die es uns ermöglichen
flüchtlinge die mit einem schiff in
italien ankommen auf die anderen eu
länder zu verteilen
der neue mechanismus ist keineswegs
schon beschlossen aber von horst
seehofer ins spiel gebracht einer
zeitung sagt er heute
wenn alles bleibt wie besprochen können
wir 25 prozent der aus seenot geretteten
menschen übernehmen die vor italien
auftauchen das wird unsere
migrationspolitik nicht überfordern
seehofer ist damit der erste europäische
innenminister der eine verbindliche
aufnahmequote laut nennt die hoffnung
ist dass frankreich und andere
nachziehen überfällig sagen die grünen
so dass nicht jedes mal wenn menschen an
landen dann wieder neu die debatte los
geht oder sogar schon wenn sie noch in
seenot gerettet auf dem schiff sind sie
nicht landen können weil nicht klar ist
welches land sie aufnehmen
seit juni 2018 hat deutschland insgesamt
556 aus seenot gerettet aufgenommen
das entspricht schon jetzt etwa jedem
vierten bootsflüchtlinge die afg aber
übt scharfe kritik an seehofer überholt
die grünen jetzt links ergibt alles auf
was er und die csu bislang gesagt haben
das offenbart im prinzip sein scheitern
im amt die ocean viking soll heute abend
in lampedusa eintreffen noch im
september wollen europas innenminister
endlich eine dauerhafte lösung für die
verteilung von bootsflüchtlingen finden
tausende freiwillige leisten heute
ehrenamtlichen putzdienst und zwar am
rhein
zum zweiten mal findet dort die wohl
größte müllsammelaktion europas statt
titel reihen cleanup auf 1237 kilometern
ist am ufer einiges liegen geblieben
besonders problematisch ist plastik bis
zu 380 tonnen schwemmt der rhein jedes
jahr in die nordsee gut die hälfte des
plastiks in den weltmeeren wird über
flüsse dorthin transportiert nur ein
kleiner teil schwimmt sichtbar an der
oberfläche
das meiste jedoch ist unsichtbar denn
durch sonnenstrahlen also uv licht
wasser und bewegung zersetzt sich das
plastik in winzige partikel im mikro
plastik damit es erst gar nicht so weit
kommt schwärmen die müllsammler aus
peter böhme berichtet metall heute baum
müll tausende zigarettenkippen schon
interessant was immer und am rhein so
alles rum licht student in china findet
party müll einen grillrost und reste von
pizza kartons
[Musik]
ihr habt ja hergebracht warum könnt das
nicht auch wieder mitnehmen ist lehrer
als vorher also leichter ein paar meter
weiter isabel rath mit ihren kindern
müllsammeln als erziehungs option um den
kindern zu zeigen dass unsere umwelt
schützenswert ist und dass jeder ein
bisschen was dazu beitragen muss rein
cleanup den rein sauber machen das
geschah heute an über 100 orten entlang
des rheins über 20.000 freiwillige
doppelt so viele wie letztes jahr zogen
los um aufzuräumen
wie hier in mainz ich finde wir
produzieren so viel mühe machen uns
wenig gedanken darum wo es am ende
landet und ich find's richtig sich auch
zu engagieren nicht nur darüber
nachzudenken und zu meckern jeder sollte
sich an die eigene nase fassen und
überlegen was er kauft was er an plastik
konsumiert plastikmüll becher tüten
flaschen
die flüsse sind die fließbänder die den
müll in die meere bringen vögel und
fische können qualvoll daran verenden
mir ist klar dass wir mit einer aktion
wie dieser auch wenn wir 200 tonnen müll
einsammeln die welt nicht retten werden
aber ich glaube dass wir da ein signal
aussenden können und dieses signal heißt
leute ändert euer bewusstsein der rhein
und seine ufer sind heute ein bisschen
sauberer geworden im nächsten jahr wird
wieder aufgeräumt
und auch das gilt ab heute neue regeln
beim online-banking ausgedruckten
tan-listen können sie im prinzip
wegschmeißen die gelten nämlich nicht
mehr
hintergrund ist die neue zahlungsdienste
richtlinie der eu die das ganze sicherer
machen soll alles wichtige hat jetzt
david sauer
so fing online banking für viele an wenn
die nummer aus der tan-liste eingegeben
wurde streicht man sie durch das war
einfach aber unsicher deshalb ist damit
jetzt schluss ab heute müssen kunden
beim online banking mit zwei voneinander
unabhängigen komponenten ihre identität
nachweisen
zunächst mit einer pin oder einem
passwort und dann entweder per tan
generator oder smartphone auf das itan
geschickt wird oder mit biometrischen
merkmalen zb fingerabdruck oder
gesichtserkennung diese zwei faktor
authentifizierung macht das online
banking sicherer aber auch aufwendiger
sicher kann man nicht übertreiben bin
ich auch offen für neue ist habe ich
schon neue pins oder tan zimmer mein
handy habe ich schon alles gemacht ohne
smartphone geht ab sofort wenig von
vielen banken gibt es eine app die die
tan generiert möglich aber auch dass
foto tan verfahren einfach den barcode
scannen den rest macht das handy
das kann natürlich nur funktioniert wenn
man auf zwei geräten nutzt es wird mit
sicherheit wieder ein paar leute geben
die ihr smartphone jetzt schon zum
online banking nutzen die auch dem
gleichen smartphone dann auch die app
installieren
aber es geht auch ohne handy mit der
sogenannten flittern
der generator hat keine verbindung zum
internet und ist deshalb besonders
sicher kostet ab 20 euro
auch wer im netz per kreditkarte zahlen
will braucht bald zwei faktor
authentifizierung dafür aber hat der
handel einen aufschub bekommen bis zu
drei jahre
wer das ganze nochmal in ruhe anschauen
möchte alles wichtige zur
zwei-faktor-authentifizierung haben wir
zum nachlesen auf heute.de für sie
zusammengestellt in saudi arabien ist
die grösste erdölraffinerie des landes
mit drohnen attackiert worden inzwischen
sollen die flammen unter kontrolle sein
zu dem anschlag bekannten sich die
jemenitischen rebellen seit monaten
verschaffen sie mit terrorakten die
andere
die situation in der golfregion die
staatliche öl verarbeitungsanlage ist
wichtig für die weltweite versorgung mit
erdöl stolz nimmt sich südafrika
regenbogen nation weil hier menschen mit
jeder erdenklichen farbe aus aller welt
friedlich zusammenleben
soweit die theorie die realität sieht
immer öfter anders aus zuwanderer aus
anderen afrikanischen ländern werden
angegriffen ihre leben zerstört die
rassentrennung ist geschichte aber die
armut sorgt weiter für viel unfrieden
tim krüger berichtet steven ätherisch
stammt aus nigeria und hatte einen
großen traum er wollte fußballer werden
in südafrika als das nicht funktionierte
eröffnete er hier einen friseursalon der
aber wurde bei den jüngsten angriffen
auf ausländer zerstört nun wollen er und
seine familie nur noch weg ich habe
große angst diese gewalt ist zu viel ich
werde mit meinen kindern nach hause
zurückkehren es sind zu viele
plünderungen und kämpfen im laufe der
woche hatten bereits knapp 200 menschen
das angebot einer fluggesellschaft
genutzt kostenfrei nach nigeria zurück
zu kehren insgesamt 600 wollen dem land
am kap der guten hoffnung den rücken
kehren
ich sage euch die situation war
entsetzlich wir hatten alle angst
der grund tage lang kam es anfang
september in südafrika zu gewalttätigen
angriffen gegen ausländer
dabei wurden geschäfte geplündert und
zerstört nicht zum ersten mal
die menschen sind sauer auf die
regierungen das richtet sich gegen diese
leute die regierung lässt viele
ausländer ohne ausbildung ins land die
straßenbahn als maurer arbeiten
dabei gibt es viele südafrikaner die
diese jobs übernehmen wollen
du kannst nicht menschen angreifen weil
sie ausländer sind das ist schlecht für
unser land und unsere wirtschaft
in der tat waren die reaktionen heftig
in nigeria und sambia etwa kam es zu
übergriffen auf südafrikanische
unternehmen und vertretungen
immer wieder haben wir in den
vergangenen wochen über die verheerenden
brände in den regenwäldern berichtet
heute am tag der tropenwälder schauen
wir noch einmal hin
der amazonas regenwald ist die grüne
lunge der erde und massiv bedroht vor
allem in brasilien wo agrar bauern
gezielt große areale für mehr ackerland
und weideflächen abbrennen es geht aber
auch anders zeigt christoph reckert
mauro ist großgrundbesitzer und stolzer
rinder baron in dritter generation vom
rücken seines maltese aus herrschte er
über seine gigantische ranch im
brasilianischen bundesstaat pará amazone
und doch ist er anders ausgeschert aus
der herde der brasilianischen züchter
denn er will den regenwald bewahren
[Musik]
diese mehr davon dass man mehr abholzen
muss um zu wachsen ist blödsinn
stattdessen müssen wir unsere
produktivität erhöhen auf den flächen
die wir bereits haben wie
haifischflossen aus dem meer ragen die
hacker der zebu rinder aus dem hohen
gras dass mauro hier extra anpflanzt er
denkt die böden wechselt alle paar tage
die weiten so kann er auf gleicher
fläche viermal so viele rinder ernähren
wie seine kollegen die immer neuen wald
für ihre rinder roden moore dagegen
pflanzt neue bäume eine schnell
wachsende sorte deren holz viel geld
bringt und selbst wenn er die in ein
paar jahren gewinnbringend abholzt
entsteht hier ganz nebenbei ein neues
stück regenwald die jungen gepflanzten
bäume stehen in geraden fast sterilen
reihen aber sie spenden schatten und das
ist der entscheidende anfang je weiter
wir nach hinten gehen zu den älteren
bäumen desto dichter wird die vegetation
im schutz der gepflanzten bäume erobert
sich der regenwald sein territorium
zurück und bis das soweit ist pflanzt
mauro hier eine besonders nahrhafte gras
sorte für seine rinder
gleichzeitig erhält er die einzigartige
biologische vielfalt des regenwaldes ein
gütesiegel für sein produkt niemand auf
der welt produziert fleisch in so einer
sich artigen umgebung wir müssen uns gut
um unsere wälder kümmern denn das
steigert auch den wert unserer produkte
am ende sei ein intakter regenwald
schlicht besser fürs geschäft gibt uns
mit auf den weg das müsse jetzt nur noch
seine regierung begreifen
er hätte sicher seine freude gehabt an
der weit sich dieses großgrundbesitzers
alexander von humboldt umweltschützer
weltweit gefeierter universalgelehrte
bis heute begeistern seine reiseberichte
und abenteuer im frühen neunzehnten
jahrhundert hat er die regenwälder
südamerikas erkundet und sich durch die
eisige tundra sibiriens bis nach
zentralasien durchgekämpft heute wäre er
250 jahre alt geworden
stephan merseburger erinnert das
humboldt forum im rekonstruierten
berliner schloss ist zwar nicht fertig
gebaut aber der runde geburtstag ist nun
einmal heute also wird der große stellt
erkläre alexander von humboldt gefeiert
sein vermächtnis ist aktuell wie eh und
je
leider auch angesichts rassistische und
nationalistische ab und ausgrenzung
er war naturforscher abenteurer
umweltaktivist und universalgelehrter
ihn interessierte das große ganze er
wollte die gesamte welt verstehen seine
erste und vielleicht wichtigste
expedition führte ihn nach lateinamerika
pflanzen tiere chemie physik philosophie
alles interessierte ihn
er zeichnete und schrieb unentwegt
humboldt setzte sich für die rechte der
indigenen bevölkerung ein und war ein
erklärter gegner der sklaverei indigene
aus dem amazonasgebiet sind nach berlin
gekommen und haben so ist es bei ihnen
brauch wenn ein haus neu ist dem
humboldtforum mit einer zeremonie ihren
segen gegeben eine botschaft haben sie
auch mitgebracht alle staaten und
regierungen sollen unsere art zu leben
respektieren und dafür garantieren
so wird die ostfassade des
humboldt-forums heute abend erstrahlen
indigene malen sternbilder die ihnen
seit jahrhunderten wichtige erkenntnisse
über den jahreszyklus geben heute ist
ihr leben im einklang mit der natur am
amazonas bedroht humboldt würde dagegen
lautstark kämpfen
[Musik]
eine kritische stimme die in ganz europa
gehört wurde mit der bekannteste autor
seines landes und holocaust überlebende
jetzt ist der ungar georgi konrad 86
jährig gestorben er schrieb über das was
er erlebt hatte und legte sich dabei ab
den 60er jahren mit ungarns führung an
etwa in seinem debüt-roman der besucher
reiseverbot berufsverbot beides konnte
ihn nicht stoppen
und auch nach der wende blieb er eine
moralische instanz und ein
leidenschaftlicher kämpfer für europa
nach den heftigen regenfällen in spanien
ist die zahl der toten auf mindestens
sechs gestiegen ministerpräsident
sanchez überflog die am stärksten
betroffenen gebiete im osten und
südosten des landes vor allem die
regionen um valencia und murcia leiden
unter massiven überschwemmungen etwa
3000 rettungskräfte sind im einsatz
die behörden warnen vor weiteren
niederschlägen jetzt ein ganz anderes
thema norbert manchen männern sieht man
ihr alter einfach nicht anders und dazu
gehört günter netzer zum beispiel ganz
genau
vielleicht hält die begeisterung für den
fußballsport ja jung er ist weltmeister
geworden und europameister heute feiert
günter netzer als eine der
vielseitigsten legenden des deutschen
fußballs seinen 75 geburtstag und er
wird gewiss auch heute angesprochen auf
seinen denkwürdigen treffer für borussia
mönchengladbach im pokalfinale 1973 als
er sich in der verlängerung selbst
eingewechselt hatte und das 2 1-siegtor
gegen den rheinischen rivalen herrscht
fc köln erzielte der übrigens auch heute
in der bundesliga nicht mit einem
solchen treffer aber den kürzeren
gezogen hat denn players tor nach 14
minuten beschert borussia
mönchengladbach auswärts drei punkte
beim alten rivalen die andere borussia
in torlaune 14 0 gegen leverkusen dran 3
x 2 1 meins mit den ersten punkten gegen
die hertha augsburgs erster saisonsieg
gegen frankfurt und union verliert
daheim gegen werder bremen leipzig gegen
die bayern läuft das top spiel
ausführlich im aktuellen sportstudio mit
kölns trainer achim beierlorzer als gast
gestern düsseldorf gegen wolfsburg 1 zu
1 dortmund wird die tabellenführung
nachher wieder abgeben müssen an leipzig
oder die bayern wolfsburg kann auf vier
zurückfallen bei der bremen springt mit
dem zweiten sieg vorläufig in die obere
hälfte könnte aber morgen von hoffenheim
und schalke überholt werden
mainz 05 befördert mit dem ersten
saisonsieg den heutigen gegner hertha
bsc ans tabellenende
für den fc liverpool ist nur die
tabellenspitze ein thema die reds von
jürgen klopp bleiben als einziges team
der premier league ohne punktverlust
nach dem 3 1 gegen newcastle united
standing ovations für jürgen klopp der
sich gut gelaunt war im liverpooler
publikum bedankt dabei hatte seine
mannschaft mit startschwierigkeiten zu
kämpfen nach sieben minuten schon der
rückstand der von eintracht frankfurt
ausgeliehene metro willems bringt
newcastle zunächst in führung
liverpool findet danach besser seinen
rhythmus und nach einer knappen halben
stunde sah die um eine eiskalt zum 1 1
ausgleich die begeisterung seines
trainers in klopp typischer
überschwänglicher manier die reds kommen
danach immer mehr in spiellaune
noch vor der pause gelingt manet der
doppelpack mit einer 2 1 führung geht
liverpool in die halbzeit und der sieg
ist in der zweiten hälfte nicht mehr
gefährdet mohammed sala erhöhte in der
72 minute nach elegantem zuspiel des ex
hoffenheimers roberto firmino zum 3 1
endstand
jürgen klopp bleibt mit liverpool
tabellenführer in der premier league und
zeigt sich gut aufgestellt für die
mission titelverteidigung in der
champions league das war's um fußball
danke schön und wir haben noch ein paar
frische bilder aus dem berliner zoo und
die zeigen uns zwei wochen nach geburt
fangen die beiden punker zwillinge
tatsächlich an ein bisschen wie man das
aus zu sehen stellt sich also dringend
die namensfrage horn und konnten viele
berliner passend nur vorschläge
china ist aber schon mal leicht
verstimmt und darf er auch mitreden denn
obwohl geschenkt gehören pandas
lebenslang dem reich der mitte fehlt
noch das wetter morgen im süden viel
sonne und heiß wo es regen gibt sagt ihm
gleich ist intern christian sievers
begrüßt sie um viertel nach elf
heute journal wir sagen tschüss und
freuen uns wenn sie morgen wieder lust
haben dabei zu sein machen sie sich ein
schönes wochenende eine gute und
herzlich willkommen zum wetter eine
hochdruckbrücke reicht vom atlantik über
frankreich bis nach deutschland ja und
löst die meisten wolken auf aber wir
haben auch noch hier ein tief über
skandinavien und das schiebt hier eine
kaltfront langsam südwärts auch nach
deutschland und so bekommen wir morgen
regen der kommenden nacht klart es auf
vieles nicht los im süden bildet sich
nebel
und die temperaturen gehen im hessischen
bergland bis etwa 5 grad zurück also
jedoch mal ziemlich kalt am mildesten
ist es an der nordsee und im südwesten
bei 13 bis 14 grad morgen im
tagesverlauf von norden her wolken die
allmählich etwas regen bringen
in der mitte und im süden scheint häufig
die sonne teilweise staaten im süden
noch mit nebel in den tat aber sonst ist
es relativ sonnig an der ostsee aus sehr
windig temperaturen dabei sehr hoch 30
grad im südwesten hier ein heißer tag
sonst aber alle 23 bis 27 grad in der
südhälfte an den küsten sind es 18 bis
19 grad und die nächsten tage am montag
nochmal im süden bis 27 von norden her
wird es kühler in der mitte gibt es
regen 15 grad im norden dann nur noch
und ab dienstag nur noch 13 bis 19 grad
ein schöner abend